so I'll tell you about the most awkward
conversation I ever had with my dad was
in 1996 right after we got a o L was the
first thing I thought to do when we got
a o L was to create a screen name log
into a sex chat and pretend and I'm a
woman fair enough
I just didn't know that you could be
reported on a sex chat and that as a
result your dad would receive an email
with quotes as to why you were reported
unsaid sex check look look I was in
sixth grade this is mostly second base
rhetoric nothing too hardcore but I
remember doing this on a Friday night
solo sleepover as I called him back down
the next morning I came downstairs and I
sat down to the breakfast table and all
my dad said to me was did you tell
someone last night that you're too sexy
for your blouse and I lied and said it
wasn't me forgetting that my screen name
was my first middle and last name I used
to live in I used to live in New York
and I moved here recently but right
before I moved I was on the subway and
there was a guy sitting across from me
who was so attractive that it was like
irritating ID ever see someone who's so
good-looking like you kind of want them
to die like I hated him but instead of
actually hitting on him like any normal
human being would do I decided to take a
photo of him with my phone for later
here's a suggestion for anyone who would
like to covertly snap a photo of a
stranger sitting across from them on the
subway turn off the flash you're gonna
want to turn off that pesky flash
because you expose yourself as the
gayest creep in the world when the flash
went off we gave each other looks of
equal levels of astonishment and I was
so embarrassed that my first instant was
just to barf all over the place but
instead I just said loosen up and then I
got off of the next time I got a letter
recently in the mail from myself we had
an assignment in English class in high
school to write a letter to yourself in
ten years and I actually got it so I
thought it was a it was a little long so
I shortened it for you but I was kind of
adorable so this is from me from ten
years ago to your Brent well it's been
ten years since you wrote this note so
hopefully by now you've left Michigan
check started doing stand-up comedy
hello and met the woman of your dreams
it's adorable
I love how at the age of 17 the cold
reality had already dawned on me the
Michigan is like the most economically
depressed state in the country but I
conveniently chose to ignore the fact
that every single one of my wet dreams
had prominently featured Jonathan Taylor
Thomas the note continues says hopefully
your future wife will have an amazing
personality and will be entirely open to
adopting children we translate that for
you I don't want to touch my wife well
high five once a year on Christmas Day
and that'll be that
but you know I wrote him back and I
wanted to read my response for you dear
gaywad I still remember the last crush
you ever had on a girl was Dominique
Moceanu who some of you may recall from
the 1996 female Olympics gymnastics team
down in Atlanta I remember you noting -
a friend of yours at the time that you
found her particularly attractive
because and I quote her breasts are so
small and muscular
Ren Sullivan thank you